I know you like nothing more
than a number with a name, so we're going
to do Witness Numbers.
They can provide witness
for your good character - or more
specifically
they provide a witness for if a number
is prime or not. And there's nothing we
enjoy more in mathematics than working
out if a number is prime or not.
- (Brady: I'm)
(curious to know whether 747 is prime.)
Ooh that's lovely. If you add the digits
together it's 18;
so spoiler it's not prime.
It's gonna be a multiple of 9. But
let's say we don't know that,
is 747 prime?
Well here's what we're going to do,
we're going to call up a witness to
testify on behalf of 747
to say whether or not it's prime. And you
can you can choose your witness, it's any
number smaller than 747. So from now on
this is like our n, this is the number
we're interested in. What witness would
you like to call
to represent your number?
- (I'd like to)
(call the number 23.)
- 23, nice. So a is going
to be our witness 23. I'm using the
standard letters in case people want to
research this afterwards. You've called
witness 23. So first of all we've got to
prepare your n for trial; we want to
rearrange it to be powers of 2. So some-
I don't know what number we're going to
have up here, there's gonna be some
number m which will be how many 2s
there are and then that's multiplied by
some other number and then because -
okay we're assuming this is odd, this
actually this works for odd n greater
than 2. And if it's not an odd n
greater than 2 it's pretty obvious if
it's prime or not, so we don't worry
about that. So this is definitely going
to be odd and that's going to give us
something even because we're multiplying
by a whole bunch of 2s plus 1. So
this is the form we want to put our
number in just to get it ready. It's like
putting on a suit and a tie when you go
to court. So actually let's get a
calculator, I'm trying to minimise the
mistakes this time.
- (Minimise the mistakes?)
Not eradicate, just- you know I'm
trying to cut back. Okay so we got
seven hundred and forty-
we're gonna take one off so it's gonna
be 6. And I'm just gonna see if I can
divide it by 2;
I can - 2 goes into it once.
Is that it?
That's it. Okay right cool, that'll be
easy. So that's going to be 2 to the
power of 1 times 373.
So now our m is 1 and d the leftover
chunk is 373. So what you're doing is
you're going, let's pretend it's a power
of 2 but then
we've got to multiply it by something
and add 1 to- because it's not
actually a power of 2 but this is this- if
it was that's you know what it would be.
Okay so now we're going to ask, right a:
is a
to the power of whatever this d; is does
that equal 1 mod n, that's our
question, very simple question. And it's
either going to say yes or no and so
let's find out shall we? So we've got to
do-
we're going to do 23
to the power of 300 - terrible choice
Brady-
- (Brady: Sorry...)
I hate to be retrospectively
critical of your choice,
oh my goodness. Now computationally it's
not that bad because of this mod. So if I
said what's 23 to the power of 373? It
would be a nightmare because that's
going to be like an outrageously big
number.
But because we can mod it by n each time
we're never going to have a number at any
point that's bigger than 747. So each
time we multiply 23 by 23 by 23 by 23 we
just keep modding by 747. I'm
going to cheat and ask Wolfram Alpha.
747- kay I've Wolfram Alpha'd
that and
we did- we did 23 to the power of 373
mod 747 and it was 131. Now this is not
1. It's got some 1s in it but that's
not what we're after. In this case the
first witness has come up and said nah
not prime. And if a single witness says
not prime,
not prime.
That's it, the number is kicked out of
the court or whatever this the prime
test place, they are turfed out they are
not a prime number the moment of witness
says no.
- (So this is foolproof Matt? If we)
(get 1)
(we can take it to the bank?)
- No.
So
this is how it works: if a witness says
not prime you can totally believe them.
No witness is ever going to lie and
say it's not prime and it actually is.
However,
some witnesses will lie
and say it's prime when it's not. So
you'll never get a false negative
you will occasionally get a false
positive. So not all witnesses
are reliable when they say yes - and
they're literally called liars, they're
called strong liars because they give an
absolutely definitely 100 that number's
prime,
you have to believe me, and they're lying.
(A non-1 we can trust? You fail.)
- Yep yep
(But a 1 isn't an absolute guarantee?)
- No
not an absolute guarantee. I'll tell you
what, let me do another one and I'll show
you I'll show you a liar in action. So
same style as before but this time our
number again is not a prime. So we're
going to do n equals 91,
not a prime number. We're going to call a
witness, we're going to call the number
10. Maybe, all right, 10 get in here, we
want to hear all about 91. Well first of
all we've got to get them all dressed up
for court and so that's going to be our
plus 1 at the end, that's going to leave
us with 90. So we're going to have 2 to
the 1 times 45. So our d value is 45.
Okay so we get a and we're like, rightio a,
10 to the power of 45 which is going to
be very big number - what does that equal
if we're going mod 91? So
having a good old-fashioned think - given
us 90. Now first of all you're thinking,
hang on, failed the test.
However interestingly, 90
is negative 1 mod 91 because it's one
below. And so actually we will accept
positive or negative 1.
- (All right so)
(that that should be a
pass actually then?)
Yeah so it's passed, so 10s like nah
checks out, love it,
put it in the mix. And you're like okay
do we trust 10? Let's say we picked a
number below 91 at random and the number
says yep it's prime and you're like, well
I don't know how much I trust it, should
we check another one? Well I happen to
know
below 91 there are 19 numbers, so there's
90 possible witnesses we could call of
those 18 of them are liars. So
there's an 18 out of 90 chance that when
we picked a number at
random - I happened to
know 10 was a liar -
it's going to be a liar. And so now
you're like, well hang on how does this
help? And so sadly at the moment what we
have is a probabilistic
primality
test. So it'll- it it's an absolute
composite number test, if it says it's
composite it is, if it says it's prime
you're like,
I don't know. Now if every number- you're
like forget it bring all 90 possible
witnesses in here; if all 90 of them are
like nah it's definitely prime then it's
definitely prime.
- (So you can't have all liars?)
Can't have all liars. So 18 is
just below
a quarter of 90, this is one of the
worst cases, but for any number
maximum a quarter of the possible
witnesses will be liars. And so now
you can just keep calling up witnesses
at random - and it has to be at random -
that are smaller than the number you're
testing and each time you test it, worst
case there's a one in four chance. And so
what you can say is if you do k tests,
and you're picking properly at random, if
they all say it's prime for k times then
there's a one over four to the k chance
it's not actually prime - worst case. This
is- now now we're talking about
probabilities of probabilities because
it's it's below this, that's like your
worst case. So it's that or better. So
what you do is you're like, well, you know
what if I want to be
99.9%
sure
you just do enough tests to get you past
that limit. And so because
computationally
doing multiplications and mods, computers
are very happy with that. Oh and the one
extra
thing you can do is a witness
can request
that as well as just having this d at
the front
it can have any extra multiples of 2
at the front
but not as many as the original
breakdown. So here we had a 2, here we
had one 2;
if this had been something like 2
cubed or 2 to the four
then you could put in a bunch of 2s
here and if any of them give you a 1
or a negative 1 then that's a yes.
So you've got to check a few things, all
of them are very fast for computers to
do, and so when you go to one of these
websites - is this number prime? And it's
like pretty sure it's prime, what it's
doing is it's doing a test like this,
often this exact test, and it's using
that to just be able to say with some
level of confidence yeah we're pretty
sure that's prime.
- (In the case of 91)
(10 is a liar? Along with 17)
- 10s a liar.
(other numbers you said?)
- Correct.
(Is there a number that is notorious for)
(being a liar more often than other)
(numbers?)
- You know, you are so close. The
opposite - there are star witnesses. There
are some witnesses where
if you if you're going to pick anyone
the this is the A-team of witnesses you
want to call upon. In fact they're so
good that you don't even have to call
any non-star witnesses.
So I said you could just check all the
numbers; in fact for any number below
a trillion
there's a squad of four witnesses, and if
you ask all four of them and they all
sign off on it, you're guaranteed. Let's
meet them - here we go.
(Well my word yes!)
(These are celebrities!)
These are- there are-
okay let's get some more paper. I
should also say that this is called the
Miller-Rabbin Test. And you can do the
probabilistic version or you call up
your star witnesses and then you know. So
if your only witnesses are 2 and 3,
if they cosign, and say, nah great number,
definitely a prime, that will work for
any number up to 1,373,653.
Any number below that, if you
just asked 2 and 3, you're good. Now
that that is a speedy primality test.
Interestingly you'll have no idea what
the prime factors are of this number; and
I'm
fascinated by prime tests where you
don't divide, and you don't even know
what the factors are, you just know they
exist - I find that so interesting.
- (But at)
(that point for that number there)
(one of those two will lie?)
- Yeah one of
them cracks. I don't know what this
number did
to one of these but there's been some
witness tampering going on and they've
now got- they're now they're now upset. So
what you do is you bring in another
witness, you're like okay from now on
we're doing 2, we're doing 3, and
we're doing 5.
Very primey, get to that in a moment. Now
5, not only does 5 sort out this
one, 5 gets you all the way up to 25
million. Specifically
25 million 326 thousand
and 1.
So it'll break on this number. So it
works all the way up to a thousand flat.
And so by bringing
in one extra star- we've
only got three star witnesses, you're
doing all right. That said we could have
in here; like let's say we're so
disappointed
that that these witnesses let us down,
these folks were unreliable for this
number, we're like get out of here. You
know what, we're going to replace you
with a equals 31 or 73. I mean bigger
chunkier numbers,
but if you just use these two as
witnesses that works all the way up to 9
million
80 thousand
191. Better star witnesses; if you've only
got space for two
then I would recommend bringing in 31
and 73. They make a bit more mess, they're
not as well behaved as 2 and 3 but
they will get you you know over eight
times as far.
- (They're hostile witnesses)
(but they're honest.)
- Exactly yeah yeah,
they get they get it done.
People may not approve of their methods,
get the job done. And then
before I said the the squad of four. So
this is- if you bring in and like this is
like for a really important case, you're
like you know what we cannot mess around.
And these these folks were only
discovered in 1993.
- (These are expert witnesses?)
These are expert, they're like
this is the A-team. 2,
classic 2. Forget 3 though, you want
to bring in 13, you want to bring in 23,
and then the team captain:
1,662,803.
They're a real maverick.
So
not good to work with,
they've been many times
they've had to hand
in their badge, all that,
but they will crack
the hardest of holdouts. So these guys
will get you oh- these are the guys who
get you over a quadrillion.
- (So this is)
(like a good cop, bad cop?)
- Oh yeah! This is good
yeah good cop,
bad cop;
gets results.
These get you all the way up to - oh my
goodness - one quadrillion,
122 trillion, four
million six hundred and sixty nine
thousand, six hundred and thirty
three. So good reach,
they don't mess around.
(All right Matt, you've shown me the star)
(witnesses but you still haven't told me)
(who are the liars!)
- You know, I don't know!
I- it had not occurred to me to look up
who were the least reliable. And so- I
mean you could do it, you just have to- if
someone wants to write some code
and put the answer in the comments below,
I think it'd be very interesting. You
just have to go through every single
number, find out how many strong liars
it's got when you put it through the
Miller-Rabbin test. Score each number for
how often it shows up as a liar; and then
we'll know who the most dishonest
numbers are. These are the honest numbers.
Oh by the way if you wanted- if this
proves to be too much you can actually
replace them with two friendlier
numbers, you can switch to 2,
3, 5,
7,
11.
I mean you just- you're
back to the primes.
So actually runs of primes are really
good; they get you all the way up to 2
trillion, 152
billion, 302 million, 898
thousand-
oh
747.
That's put a little bow on this video
hasn't it? Yeah so it depends if you
would rather have fewer but unruly
witnesses; or you prepared- you've got
like a fifth chair and you bring you you
can bring in 7 and 11 to to do the
lifting so.
- (Oh what you need to do is you)
(need to find out what the 12 best are)
(and call them the 12-)
- 12 good numbers!
"You can't handle the truth."
- (12 angry numbers?
I bet there is a 12 - hang on. So if you
want, I'll put them in red for being angry.
So here's your-
they don't take any malarkey from anyone.
You're bringing in 2, you're bringing
in 3,
5, oh this is just
the primes 7, 11, 13, 17, 19,
23,
29,
31,
and 37. Just off the top of my head, that
will get you up to 308
sextillion I assume? 665
quintillion,
857 quadrillion - I'm just gonna write the
numbers out. Or
approximately 10 to the 23, that's the
kind of order of magnitude you're
looking at.
- (You'd have to use all twelve?)
You've got to use- they they all have to
be- you can't have a hung jury, it's
you've got to have completely unanimous.
They've all got to be like yep
and in unison as a team if they all say
yes, they're right.
Whether it's prime numbers, composite
numbers or almost anything else; why not
sharpen your skills with the amazing
array of courses on Brilliant, today's
episode sponsor.
For a deeper understanding of how things
work, you just can't beat interactivity;
and that is Brilliant's stock and trade
as you can see.
I can't really decide if this is
recreation or education - I guess it's
both. I recommend you check out Brilliant,
and if you're already signed up why not
consider giving Brilliant as a gift to
someone else? That inquisitive nephew
maybe or how about that auntie who's
always been a lifelong learner. There's
plenty of free stuff on the site, but
Brilliant are offering a 20% discount on
their all-inclusive premium package by
using the url brilliant.org/Numberphile
It's there on the screen and
in the description. Give them a look,
Brilliant, they're great people and
they're making amazing stuff.